>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Edward Ayers will kick off
the Collections as Data Stories
with History Between the Lines
thinking about collections as Data.
Ed is the Tucker-Boatwright
Professor of Humanities
and the President Emeritus of
the University of Richmond.
President Barack Obama awarded
him the National Humanities Medal
in 2013 for his dedication
to public history.
Over his decades of work Ed
has tried to find new ways
to connect people with
the American past.
Current projects include the
BackStory Podcast, bunkhistory.org,
the American Civil War Museum,
and serving as President
of the Organization of
American Historians.
Please welcome Ed Ayers.
[Applause]
>> Edward Ayers: Good morning.
Good to see everybody.
So I've been asked to cover several
decades of digital assessments.
I've been at this for
several decades.
And you might think I'd
have it figured out by now,
but I don't because the
frontier keeps moving on us.
And it's really exciting to think
about where we are
and where we've been.
And I think the revolution
that we're living
through now began before
the digital, though.
I think it actually began, this is
a dangerous thing to say in front
of people who actually
know the truth on this,
but there's no Q&A right now so you
can't challenge me at this second.
I believe that the
revolution actually began
with the microfilm revolution in
the 1930s and the 40s and the 50s
when we unlocked this remarkable
technology that will allow us
to have all the newspapers
in American history
that would have the
United States Census,
all these bountiful documents
available to researchers anywhere
for a relatively small cost.
And even though microfilm
seems distinctly unsexy today,
it was my introduction not only
to all things digital
but to history itself.
I wasn't sure what I wanted to do
even when I was in graduate school.
But one day I went
into the microform room
and started reading newspapers
on one of those big sort
of World War II era gray steel
things with the cranks on it.
And there in front of me I
saw something remarkable.
These newspapers demonstrated
something that I had not realized.
People didn't know what was
going to happen the next day.
And all this stuff was
happening at the same time.
That you would see on one page the
news I recognized in the textbooks,
and then on all the other
pages beneath all kinds
of fascinating things, evolution
of life before our very eyes.
And I realized that's what I'm
interested in is all that resonance
and interaction, that space between
the lines, that sense of possibility
that was on every screen of
that old scratched microfilm
on that archaic device.
So I wrote my dissertation
partly on that.
And when I became a teacher I
said, you know, it would be fun
to introduce all these young
people to the glories of microfilm.
And so I sent them into the
microforms room in front
of these machines and they
were completely addled.
This is in the 80s.
And the entire assignment was read
a year of this newspaper and write
about something interesting in it.
And all the pre-meds and people
in the classroom were
just freaking out.
But what's the assignment?
That is the assignment.
What's the question?
That's for you to find
out and to answer it.
And the course evaluations come
back at the end of the semester
and they said, well, we
didn't like Ayers that much,
but seeing history raw was one
of the most exciting things
that I've done in my
college education.
So I already knew that that magic,
that power lay in that medium.
One day I was in the library
and I saw a gleaming black
NeXT machine in 1990.
And I saw that as amazing as it
seemed at that time that images
of microfilm and census and letters
and diaries and maps could be seen
on a computer screen in color.
Now, the web didn't exist
yet but look at that.
So friends of mine in
the library told me
about a magical thing called SGML.
I'm pandering to the
librarians in the room,
so Standard Generalized Markup
Language, or as we called it,
Sounds Good, Maybe Later.
And we saw in that a
way to build something
that would identify all
these different objections
in the collections and
connect them with each other.
So I had this idea, hey, we have
this capacity, what do you say
that we share with people
who don't have access
to a major resource library,
who don't have a bank
of microfilm readers or microfilm,
a way to get that excitement
for themselves.
Now, we didn't have any idea of
how we would distribute that,
some kind of tape, some kind of hard
devices, but we started building it.
And then one day a
friend called me down
and said you need to see this, Ed.
Here's something they're calling
the World Wide Web, and it's based
on a baby version of SGML.
We could make what
they're calling a site
for this World Wide
Web pretty quickly.
And so we did.
And so we were out there at the
very beginning before we were ready,
before we had really any
idea what we were doing.
But what we did know is that
suddenly if you had plenty
of patience you could watch an image
of a newspaper very slowly appear
on your screen over
that 2400 baud modem.
And people liked it and
the letters and docs.
So we started building a mountain.
And we built this first project
that many of you may have heard of,
The Valley of the Shadow.
The short version of it is
every piece of information
about every person who lived
in a northern community
and a southern community throughout
the entire American Civil War.
It really does exist.
And you see what we did
is we emulated an archive.
And this was really, really hard to
build, it took us 14 years to do it.
Because what we were
doing is transcribing
by hand 10,000 pages of newspapers.
And these convenient things
called pdf files didn't exist
when we started.
So we actually had to write a script
to show a group 4 fax
TIFF compression image
to be able to disseminate those.
And then many, many thousands of
letters and diaries and all this.
And this came out in the mid 90s.
And then in 2003 I wrote
an analog book about it.
At the beginning it says, by
the way, this is based entirely
on additional archive that you can
see every source that I've used.
And that came out in 2003.
And then I became Dean of Arts and
Sciences at UVA, and then I left UVA
to become President at Richmond.
And when I did, this is important
for all things we're talking
about today, University of Virginia
rather than being mad at me, said,
wow, we've been happy to oversee
in the library the creation
of this big thing, what do you say
that we make sure that if Ed, say,
gives a talk at the Library
of Congress in 2017 ten years
from now that it still works.
Or that he writes volume two
out of The Valley of the Shadow
which I just did at bookstores
near you in October, The Thin Light
of Freedom, and here's the thing.
I sat there and hit on this thing
as hard as I could for a year
and a half after it
hadn't been touched
for seven years and it still works.
That's because of the people at the
University of Virginia who went back
through and checked every linked
and made sure it all still works.
That's important because
sometimes we wonder if the things
that we are making in this
digital environment are going
to endure the way that the
things, even microfilm,
which I believe is right
there with cockroaches
in durability is it going to endure?
So The Valley of the
Shadows shows that it can.
And I think that's important.
But there are other things.
When I left Virginia I
said, you know, okay,
transcribing by hand an entire
intentional archive that was fun.
But what do you say
that we take advantage
of all the pre-digitized sources
that have emerged since 1993
when we started The
Valley of the Shadow.
I bet there are lots of things
that we could put to immediate use.
When I went to the University
of Richmond I was a part
of founding the Digital Scholarship
Lab where we have many new projects.
And one of which is
American Panorama
which is a digital atlas
of American History.
And the idea there was let's take
advantage of, say, two of these.
This is the forced
migration of enslaved people.
And I really do want to explore it.
And what it does is based
on the United States Census
which is already in machine readable
form, let's make a kind of map
of the slave trade and the
movement of African-American people
across the vast expanse
of the American South.
The idea was to see things
that we could not see before
but that were already hidden
between the lines of the data.
Being able to see the
areas of the south
that were losing enormous
numbers of people and others
who were gaining enormous numbers.
And we built all this with
an open source set of tools
that can be shared
with other people.
Other people can make these maps.
And I would say that when I say
we I don't literally mean me.
I mean my colleagues, Rod Nelson
[assumed spelling], Justin Madron
and Nate Ayers [assumed
spelling] who made these projects
and are tapping into the capacities
of collections we already have.
The other one that we made was
the foreign-born population
of the United States
from 1850 to 2010.
And in this case to
be able to see --
okay, that gives you an idea of
what it looks like, and we can click
on a county, and it will show you
all the places that all the people
in that place came
from in that year.
So what you'll see is that
we are displaying data
in four or five different ways.
There's the very slow where
the people are coming from,
and it will send out tendrils
into all these places.
Back on the foreign- born --
I mean on the forced migration map
we could have clicked on thing,
and it would have had
the narratives of people
who were swept up in all of this.
So here's something.
We were able to make a map
that got widespread attention
from sources that already exist.
And we're able to make
these with some speed now.
And one we had last year and, again,
since I didn't make I can brag
on it, was named one of the
15 top maps in the world
by National Geographic
about mapping inequalities,
a collaborative project of Richmond,
Johns Hopkins and the University
of Maryland, Virginia Tech,
too, to show how it was
that segregation became baked
into our culture and maps
of over 150 American cities.
We have a new map coming
out about urban development
that will map all the information,
a lot of it here from Washington,
about how it was that our cities
that we all know including very
small ones were transformed
in the 1960s by building
interstates through them
and bulldozing substandard housing
and all those kinds of things.
So all these had the same idea
as The Valley of the Shadow.
There is all this enormous
power within our reach
that we can make visible.
We had these numbers about
where people came from
and all these places every year,
but if you can't see it you don't
really know what it possesses.
And my dream, too, is that
every middle school kid
in America will be able to
click on her county and see how
that has evolved over the
course of American history.
To see that the United States has
always been together of people
from a broad range of places.
The things we're talking about
today are just the latest stage
in a very long conversation.
So with the American Panorama
Digital Scholarship Lab,
the idea there is kind of The Valley
of the Shadow turned wrong side out.
Instead of taking an
archive that's scattered all
around peoples' attics,
neglected and making it visible
which was a worthy thing to do, what
do you say that we take advantage
of enormous resources
that have been created
and making things machine readable?
But that still didn't have
the newspapers I was dreaming
of over at my computer now.
So maybe switch back
to the HP and see --
the network is doing funny things
with me here, so can you go back
to that and see if we can
get Reconstructing Virginia?
Yes, we can.
So you remember how much trouble
it was for people to set there
and read newspapers on microfilm,
transcribe from scratch all the
articles, write a summary of them.
Well, thanks to Chronicling America
there are over 2,000 newspapers
and millions of pages that
have already been digitized.
What could we do with
that instead of just sort
of reading them in analog form?
Well, using a Mecca [phonetic]
from our friends at George Mason
and 16 eager first year students
at the University of Richmond,
and the Virginia Chronicle
which is the Virginia version
of Chronicling America, we said
let's go in and make visible
to the world the leading newspaper
in Virginia during this tumultuous
period of reconstruction.
And so in one semester using
the expertise of Chris Kemp
in the library at the University of
Richmond we were able to transcribe
or actually correct 2,000 articles,
and you can see what each
one of them looks like.
And each student took
responsibility.
Most of the transcription
had already been done by OCR,
but they needed to be corrected.
So they went back in
and corrected them.
Then in sort of a form of crowd
sourcing contributed those back
into the archive making the
archive better while using it.
And we have elaborate time lines and
lots of different ways to see this.
Basically in three months we did
probably what would take us three
years back on The Valley
of the Shadow
by using open source software,
things that have already been
digitized, existing standards,
a plug in, you see the time line
there is a plug in for a Mecca,
we were able with freshmen
to do something
that had been almost impossible
just a few years before.
We did an installation of this
at the Black History
Museum in Richmond.
We did a preview of that.
And so I had these
kids showing visitors
to the museum what it could do.
And we got together the next morning
and I said, well, how was that?
And they said they wanted to know
if we were graduate students.
We said, no, we're 19.
And when we think about what a
collective effort to unlock all
of the power in these newspapers
by looking at them as articles,
restoring the article structures
and the argument structure
and it's still a summary,
and then synthesizing them
into a week I think we're just at
the beginning of really seeing all
that Chronicling America can do.
So all that's good, too.
And we're getting ready to do
the Richmond Planet this fall,
one of the leading
African-American newspapers
around the turn of the century.
So I believe I need to go back
to the Mac now if I could.
I'm trying to make maximum use
of the incredible facilities here
at the Library of Congress and I am.
So this is what we're
working on now.
This is something called Bunk.
And it's named after
the Henry Ford quote
that history is more or less bunk.
Well, of course, we
don't think it is.
And he has this other thing.
He says the only history
that matters is the
history we make today.
And what we think what matters a
lot is the history, the writing
and thinking about the history
that we are making today.
I'm seeing some of you
pointing at the screen.
That's awesome.
That suggests that we're
engaging you already.
What is this?
We're curating everyday, all
representations of the American past
in all media and then putting them
in conversation with each other.
And this is not quite out yet.
This will debut very soon.
And we hope that you'll sign up for
Bunk Mail, the weekly newsletter.
And it's about the same thing
that I had the idea back
in graduate school in the 1970s.
Matter of fact you'll see
that I only had one idea
in my life actually which is,
hey, there's cool stuff here,
I wish other people could see it.
And maybe if I put it right in front
of you on your phone you would.
And that the interesting stuff
is the connections in between.
So what this does, Bunk we
are tagging all these things
as they come out.
And you'll say this is a portrait
from the Library of Congress.
But some of these things
are coming from the Atlantic
or the Washington Post, but
they're also coming from blogs
that people wouldn't
have seen otherwise.
Or they're coming from
scholarly literature.
newspapers and magazines
across the political spectrum that
don't talk to each other very much.
And they're also coming and making
-- and here's the point of Bunk.
That you realize that
there's history all around us.
People on airplanes tell me,
I'm [inaudible] I'm sitting
there grading papers or something
and they say, so, are
you a history teacher?
And I say, yeah.
And they say, yeah, I
always hated history.
All those names and dates.
And I say, yeah, I know but
that's not what history is.
And it's not really that.
It's not just tests.
And they don't realize that we're
saturated in representations
of the past all the time.
So what Bunk is trying to do
is to make us realize that most
of our movies and television shows
unless they're science fiction are
history, are based on history.
Most of them are navigating through
the complexities of our own time,
are often looking for
historical coordinates.
So here's Frederick
Douglass as a refugee.
And you can see so that the first
link there is about the Civil War,
but the next is about
other refugees, Anne Frank.
And then you can also see, okay,
now let's think about what happened
to insulate people
after emancipation.
Here's a hidden history
of Juneteenth.
And so this is Greg
Downs on Talking Point.
So part of my instinct on all
this is why it is that there is
so much wonderful history being
written in so many venues,
we've never touched more people with
American history than right now.
But there's so much of it suddenly
in so many forms and so many media
that we can't really
see it as a whole.
So Bunk is trying to do -- tried to
do with The Valley of the Shadow,
tried to do with the
Digital Scholarship Lab,
which is to gather the
power in collections
and then share them with the world.
Now, one thing about this
you'll see share connection.
So if you click on the
social media button
when this is actually available --
of course I realize that people are
out there with all kinds of laptops
now, who knows it may be available
at this very moment for all I know,
but I don't mean for it to be.
It's going to be so much
more awesome pretty soon.
But if you clicked on the
social media or the email,
what it says is look at this
cool connection I found on Bunk.
It's the two things and the
relationship between them.
And it's up to you to say isn't
that amazing how Frederick Douglass
and Anne Frank we think
of them both as refugees.
Or look at the conversations
all about monuments.
What were people saying about
this 15 years ago to be able
to understand that with some depth?
So the idea is that people
will be their own curators.
We'll tag all this.
We describe it as it's
like wrapping each
of these entries like a protein.
It can connect in lots
of different ways.
The Frederick Douglass thing it's
about African-American
history, it's about slavery.
It's also about refugees,
but it's also
about other kinds of
connections as well.
So the back end that we've
built is allowing the students
at the University of Richmond
to help us tag all these things
so they can talk to other kinds of
things, so that we can recognize
that we live in history
the way we live in oxygen.
That it is everywhere all the time
and that we can see
it in cool new ways.
So in many ways my
inspiration through all
of this has been a guy
names Vannevar Bush
who in 1945 invented a
machine that was going
to revolutionize everything.
Picture this.
First of all you wear a walnut
size camera on your forehead.
And then you have the
shutter running down your arm.
And when you see something
cool you click it
and it takes a picture of it.
And you're able to add that
archive that you're making
with all the archive of microfilm.
And he calculates that if you
added up the entire written record
of humans in 1945 it would
be in the billions he said.
But we could reduce this,
just extrapolating a bit
from current technologies and micro
photography into a moving van.
And [inaudible] he said would
cost a nickle and would sit
on a tiny corner of your desk.
And the device that would hold
all this together, the memex,
would be a series of microfilm
screens that you'd call up in front
of you, and you'd see the
connection you wanted to make,
then you'd take a picture of it.
And then you would have
added to the network
of knowledge and information.
Well, microfilm as awesome as it
is did not end up doing all that.
Could not foresee obviously
the invention
of the digital technologies
that make all that possible.
But he imagined in 1945 that there
would be a new profession of people
who make connections, of people
who are trailblazers he said
who will find all of the excitement
and the drama and the meaning
in the history between the lines.
And that's what we're
still trying to do.
And I hope all of you will
join that exciting adventure.
The Library of Congress
makes it possible.
A lot of these things are based on
the treasures that have been saved.
I like to think for just this moment
and how lucky we are to be at a time
where we have whole new ways
of envisioning this legacy.
So thank you very much
and have a great day.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.